[Musique]
c'est un italien vous allez dire dites
moi alors là parlez-moi italien je vais
fermer les yeux je vais craquer
complètement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous préférez les mecs beau gosse les
mecs intelligents les mecs comme moi bah
alors que vous êtes intelligent et beau
gosse comme vous on a plus vous êtes
habillé manoir pour moi pour vous
initier à brooke j'ai l'habitude de
chamblanc oui alors qu'elle est qu'elle
est la meilleure phrase monica pour vous
abordez pas de me dire je serai tous cas
facile l'endroit idéal pour vous donner
un premier rendez-vous qui imaginer que
je vous donne rendez-vous puisque bon là
on a un petit peu tous les deux alors un
restaurant parce que j'aime bien manger
d'accord oui c'est vrai à lyon c'est
vrai vous aimez bien manger c'est que
génial d epicure ya une vraie italien je
n'ai pas le geste qui vous fait craquer
chez un homme
les gestes qui me fait craquer à un peu
les larmes aux yeux un homme qui pleure
et non ça ne les sens pas attiré 1 et la
france parce que j'essaye de un geste
je parle ça peut être une caresse même
m² ce qu'on se ferait à soi ça peut te
va craquer le geste qui trahi votre
trouble
ag je deviens rouge géologie jeu des
plaques partout ohlala quand vous êtes
comme ça c'est que vous êtes troublé par
l'homme qui est enceinte et où elle a 10
ans qui monte à la la qu'est l'alcool
qui vous montre le plus rapidement à la
tête à tout parce qu'un effet je ne bois
pas trop et met les mains donc à lui
être qu'elle est la ville la plus
romantique selon vous monica et rome
rome paris je crois mais parle le
quartier où on a le plus de chance de
vous rencontrer l'art port à l'aéroport
bien le compliment qu'il ne faut jamais
vous faire à moi j'aime tous les
compliments sont jamais assez les
compliments celui qu'on vous a jamais
fait je crois qu'on doit inventer
[Musique]
m
au bout du dialogue on avait très envie
de se rencontrer comme ça arrive souvent
c'est sûr surtout que m'avait parlé de
bon de quoi
[Musique]
donc c'est mona c'est d'ailleurs le même
que mon prénom ki moon a aussi cédé au
hasard parce qu'il veut dire non pas
parce à l'envers mais elle se souvenait
ce possible claudia larsen parce que
tout l'effet larsen maman tu vois ma
tête je m'appelle marie rose mais parce
que j'ai permis de rencontrer des gens
que s'ils ne pourraient pas rencontrés
dans je dirais dans la vie réelle
en ce moment ça m'amuse et puis c'est
marrant c'est un plaisir ton boulot tant
bistrot quand tu veux bruits autour des
gens doit pas y en a qui drague est
vraiment c est beau la dot qui donne
comme noire accidentelle bon je me suis
aperçu qu'avec certains mots certaines
phrases certain ton on arrivait à faire
tellement rêvé l'autre de l'autre côté
qu'au bout de deux trois quatre jours
ils tombent amoureux sans nous avoir
jamais vu ça fait travailler
l'imagination c'est incroyable il ya des
histoires d'amour fantastique sur le
minitel on arrive quelquefois aller à
l'essentiel avec quelqu'un parce qu'il
n'ya pas tout réussi il a juste les mots
- 3 août va chercher femmes belles
choses
c'est un engin du diable sont classés
non c'est pas dangereux c'est pas c'est
un outil un outil n'est jamais dangereux
qui c'est très dangereux on avait vu
maints endroits suicidé quelques mois on
a eu droit des mariages ou s'ils
quittent aussi dangereux que le suicide
à mon avis je dis pas que si on ne
connaît pas le minitel on va mourir
idiot pas du tout mais disons que c'est
une chose qui parle quand même apporter
quelque chose c'est évident
[Musique]
à
ces causes est un peu ce que c'est un
coup alors que mal à des envies de
chocolat majoré du chocolat comme par
hasard c'est moi c'est comme ça
[Musique]
oh
aloès désir arrive indiqué
[Musique]
depuis quelques temps vous pouvez vous
laisser aller à tous vos fantasmes avec
le téléphone rose
osez le sexe par téléphone 200 francs la
minute à nos sos désir arrive mon biquet
elle fait ce désir et tu arrives à la
plus coquine à plus sensuelle de toutes
les réponses 2 on peut dire que tu es
bien tomber toi ils veulent bata plaisir
quel est ton type de femme
grande blonde est plutôt charge du jeu
que vous correspondez à 1115 ont-ils
correspond à des fantasmes tu peux pas
savoir
amat 72 96 60 96 les cheveux couleur ces
leaders ont beau charmant rires tu vois
quoi une belle bouche non sigean j'ai
une belle bouche sur j'aime la gauche
c'est ce que je suis en train de faire
tout de suite
on sait pas ce que j'aimerais faire
douter mais vous n'en n'ont pas tu vois
pas où tu vois pas en train de me manger
ton petit corps bouton picard la leçon
bien oui c'est ça ce matin mon petit
cousin vraiment vous dis moi m'ont
piquée au stade de la conversation là on
en a mis cet emprunt il veut poursuivre
on arrête comme tu veux euh je préfère
vous appelez le mois prochain madame eva
et bah oui d'accord c'est un peu cher
mais jean révéreault this
[Musique]
mais
ce tube like
[Musique]
un tel appareil
n'avez vous jamais tenté les pirates de
l'air ont ils jamais tenté un
détournement en vol non pas encore ça
pourrait bien m'arriver
sexuellement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les mecs qui parlent que de leur quête
ils sont persuadés qu' il faut en avoir
une grande une grosse et que leur nous
on est vachement contente et tout alors
que c'est pas du tout ça c'est pas un
travailleur de la quête je suis parti en
élite
à dix c'était bien alors pouette pouette
pour être gentil alors étudiant en vrai
c'était vachement bien pilotes on se dit
bon mais il a rien compris quoi
peut-être que le porno c'était mon
service militaire c'est les situations
violentes difficile où son image
personnelle est complètement écrabouillé
réduite à néant on est vraiment d'un
paquet de viande
y'a que ça quoi c'est que l'orgasme nous
regardent avec des espèces de mécanique
qui se secouer qui se tendent vers un
orgasme chement simple comme ça
vous parlez avec les hommes avec qui
vous avez une relation sexuelle peut
agir puisque parler de ça commence par
des motos et doux et parfois ça se finit
carrément par des grossièretés
j'aime beaucoup les photos des moments
où c'est les aventures comme ça d'un
soir on cherche pas vraiment du
romantisme on sache quelque chose de
sexuel vachement funds quoi j'ai pas
envie qu'on prenne son plaisir sur mon
dos parce que c'est les hommes rapides
ben c'est moi ça m'intéresse pas c'est
une question de y
c'est les yeux il ya des femmes du red
rat dans les yeux qui ont des draps bon
je me considère pas une femme qui a tout
les mecs à ses pieds et puis ça ne
m'intéresse même pas je vais dire ça
sert à quoi alors michel blanc est ce
qu'on peut dire de voeux vous êtes une
bombe sexuelle
maintenant on peut se poser la question
ici pierre desproges qui vous parle en
direct de monaco où se déroule
actuellement le 225e festival annuel du
film pornographique sous le haut
patronage ya pas de travail c'est trop
porno
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le film que j'ai vu pour vous hier soir
au familial ciné de monaco s'appelle oh
oui oh là là c'est bon encore oh la la
étonnant nous tout d'abord une fois de
plus de l'indigence des traducteurs qui
baptise oh oui oh là là c'est bon encore
oh là là une oeuvre dont le titre
original est au yes olala it's good once
again
oh là là mais ne faisons pas la fine
bouche à ce détail près oh oui oh là là
c'est bon ou encore oh là là est une
oeuvre attachante à bien des égards
barça
non oui bien des égards l'ours et déjà
on peut parler de chefs-d'oeuvre qu'est
ce qui se passe voilà que cette pétarade
c'est une ville très mouvementée si le
la principauté est en guerre on sepric
l'histoire bouleversante dans sa
simplicité et claire sombrement le drame
humain de 11 sténodactylographe
magistralement interprété par les
majorettes de monaco et de 14
représentants de commerce vivent en
communauté dans un lit 240 dans le plus
complet dénuement
un matin on sonne à la porte c'est le
facteur plus précisément ce sont les
facteurs puisqu'ils sont neufs
magistralement interprété par les
compagnons de la chanson par la suite
voilà voilà qu'on sonne à la porte n'est
ce pas c'est une enquêtrice de l'ifop
ou plus précisément ce sont les
enquêtrices de l'ifop puisqu'elles sont
19 magistralement interprété par les
grandes soeurs du petit rat de l'opéra
de monaco
usant d'un style elliptique qu'il
méprisait qu'ils maîtrisent pardon à
merveille depuis glissant glissons j'ai
rarement vu quelque chose d'aussi osé
l'auteur élude volontairement une
semaine entière de l'action la seule qui
ne se passe pas dans le lit de 140
alors pourquoi alors écrit l'auteur dans
le monde d'hier je cite j'ai voulu
exprimer ainsi l'incohérence des
rapports humains en milieu libéral si je
réussis je pense avoir contribué
humblement au rapprochement une femme si
j'échoue je m'en fous je suis pas au
pourcentage sur recettes voilà c'est un
film je vous répète qui est souvent très
dures quelquefois très mou mais jamais
vulgaire et j'ai c'est au cinéma
familial ciné de monaco ici pierre
desproges à vous les studios
[Musique]